what i've learned to do
and i've had panic attacks by the way
and i learned and i you know i've
run away many times
um
but what i've learned to do is when i
notice my anxiety well let me ask you
this kurt let's say that i notice my
heart racing and my throat constricting
and i start saying to myself
this is terrible you cannot do this this
is terrible
this is the worst thing this is awful
why am i like this why after 20 years do
i still get this way it's so ridiculous
get with it
what do you think will happen to my
anxiety
it won't go away it may increase and
especially if you leave in that
situation once it'll make it much more
likely for you to leave again and so
avoidance will increase as well
both yes so actually if i respond
to the physical sensations
with
rejection and why and this is awful
then it actually increases the anxiety
so now when i notice my heart racing and
my throat constricting i say okay
your heart's racing okay your throat's
constricting
this is important like this is important
for me to do so
you know i can be with this that's the
value part exactly it's you connect it
the values piece is what makes it
worthwhile like why would i put myself
in this situation
well i'll put myself in this situation
because it matters to me because this is
something i care about you know
so it provides the motivation it
provides the why for why i should do
this values are
the purpose behind
why you might do things that are
uncomfortable or difficult so
there's number one
you know just noticing my okay like my
heart's racing okay
that's okay you know my throat's go okay
my throat's constricting that happens
when i go running that happens
in many situations
but sometimes i interpret it as
dangerous and sometimes i interpret it
as pleasant
but the physical sensation itself is the
same
and so
it's like now i can say okay i'm okay i
can i can have this anxiety and still
commit to doing this because it matters
to me
is it exactly the physiologically the
same so i hear this plenty that people
will say excitement and anxiety are two
sides of the same coin except it depends
on the interpretation you place on it
one is positive but i don't know is that
actually true if one was to examine all
of the biomarkers could one in a blinded
study determine dispassionately this
actually this person's going through an
anxious emotion whereas this one's going
through an excited emotion
crazily
yes
they're the same
there's this um and i
you might want to cut this off from the
video
sure sure
you might want to cut this off but
anyways there's a there's a study
um by some famous sex therapists and
they
did a biomarker study actually
where they hooked up people who
were
you know like um blood
you know electrodermal response heart
rate few other biomarkers and they found
that the biomarkers were exactly the
same or
similar enough i guess so that's
statistically significant
that people having an orgasm were
indistinguishable from people having a
panic attack
right so well that's extremely
interesting
right and so you know the heart racing
throat constricting like feeling like
whoa right like
they were indistinguishable
on the electrodermal response and on the
heart rate and and other biomarkers
so
so yeah in a lot of ways they're not
distinguishable actually